[Musique]
marchand de sable c'est lui qui joue du
pipeau
[Musique]
bonsoir les
ils ont dû
nous étions bien loin nous étions
moi de rentrer de mai
m
avez-vous bien jouer avec lui vient
chanter
avec lui j'étais gentil c'est simple je
crois que quelques enfants ont été
plutôt méchant patron mais nous étions
en voyant
pis koldo entrons chez nous pas
non aux tilleuls
mega brands
ce seront des j'habite petit territoire
tu es trop gentil
essaye d'en nous verrons oui mais apte
condition qu'ils aient une conduite
parfait
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous allons aussi à
tue tête
bonsoir
enfin on est bien content aujourd'hui au
gallon temps
les autos l'histoire
dire bonne nuit soeur
[Musique]
bonne nuit ça fait bizarre
ap
[Musique]
ma petite fiole gens laids pour une
minute patron le temps de leur dire
bonjour et de voir s'ils ont bien reçu
tous nos cadeaux europe hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop
bonsoir les petits os je suis content de
vous revoir
alors vous avez bien reçu tous les
cadeaux qu'on vous a lancé depuis notre
nuage oui mais ce sont des potes la
moitié tombé sur le balcon de voisins oh
oui et bien tant mieux ça fera d'autres
heureux vous devriez apprendre à mieux
viser allons les enfants j'ai très peu
de temps comment tu t'en vas déjà un cas
bénin riche et demain je resterai plus
longtemps nous jouerons en sang
avec cette belle voiture oui tu sais les
bonbons ils sont excellents merci à
demain les petits je me sauve aller vite
au lit d'accord mais tu nous accompagne
et aide à la lumière bon allons au dodo
au
second enfant
tu sais nous avons vu cornichons pendant
les vacances et juliette à yves datas et
nous allons bientôt retourner chez lui
dans sa ou là tout cas ça y est bravo je
vous accompagnerai bonne nuit les
enfants
là
j'éteins la lumière
fait bourg
parmi nous
à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien gaynor je suis heureux d'avoir
retrouvé mes petits amis en patron soko
jours les jeunes allons en route bonnut
les enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents allez vite vous coucher comme
nicolas et pimprenelle n'oubliez pas de
bien vous l'a vu le don est fait de
beaux rêves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]